Hey
that was good you try not to scare me
that time welcome to the Friday review
of games as always I am Ian nee Lewis
and I'm Dan Galpin and joining us today
is the wittmers Brothers pitch black IPA
it's it's like IPA for Batman I like
that I said since since the Dark Knight
Returns is now repeat now premiering on
lots of other places in the world other
than the United States you know makes
sense for us to have a Batman brew right
right because we wouldn't want to just
you know stick to the US and ignore the
rest of the world not not that wouldn't
be our way of that it's not the Google
way by the way I have to also I
mentioned that mountain dew really let
me down you know they used to have pitch
black mountain dew which was black
exactly great but then they did a Batman
tie-in and I guess they just figured
they couldn't reuse it or whatever
exactly so what do they come up with
dark berry I know it's like a bat suit
with nipples on it exactly right mm-hmm
I know I know exactly what you're
talking about all right all right let's
get to the games we are looking at tower
defense games and that means we have a
lot of games to look at because there
are a lot of fantastically good tower
defense games on Google Play and ian has
played almost all of them but dan has
played them more recently because
yesterday while he was playing games I
was celebrating my birthday yeah
absolutely happy birthday again and
actually I wanted to apologize to all of
the Android camp participants this year
because while they were doing their
final project presentations I was
playing video games in order to prepare
for this show especially that one dude
in the back that I never learned his
name but he said he watches our show Hey
Dude how's it going all right all right
yes dude pretty long who goes to the
University of Toronto how does that
sound is that close enough all right
track him down watch out that's right
okay so tower defense games if you
watched my review of Radian defense a
couple weeks ago you'll know that
they're one of my favorite genres I
don't know why I think is you know
partly the strategy it's partly the
the fact that I can pick them up and put
them down really easily mom I don't need
great reflexes for most tower defense
games which is good yeah they're even if
you're drinking for example right oh
yeah or if you've ever seen my my
production of Rachel Myers app review
you know that my reflexes are not the
Annius in the world
move to the tablet move to the tablet
damnit so uh when we when we looked for
tower defense games I was hoping that
I'd see some new ones we actually saw a
lot that we looked at before but there
were a couple that were brand new and
there was very cool and what are we
gonna look at first well let's let's get
the let's get the junk out of the way
first
well junks copies there were some
nominations that we're going to go ahead
and reject mmm because they're not
really tower defense games yeah there
are so many schemes that that are
specific in this genre that you know
that are that to have a game that's
really not a tower defense game but this
has towers in it is is definitely
something that you know we don't need so
cartoon words for instance which is a
game not a tower defense game but a game
in which you defend a tower by the way
this is one of the this is and actually
this is bringing up something that's but
it's bring up the the tablet yeah right
oh why don't you show us what's going on
so we don't currently have no oh yeah
Rachel can you show us the tablet please
so we so when you don't have a network
you can't play the game and it just pops
of a dialog that this isn't it so sad
there are a lot of games that do this if
they require a network and it just it's
so jarring and and I want is it one I'd
like to build there's I don't think
there's any strong reason why this game
can't be played offline but to it's if
you're gonna do this make it feel like
it's actually part of the game not like
this giant error happened this is just
it's not a great user experience so and
new there are potentially things you
might want to be able to see within the
game so well I'm a little confused
actually so I played this game it's not
a bad game it's not a tower defense game
it's a it's more of a a one-dimensional
I know what would you call these like
the there was the army of Darkness a
gladiator yeah it's it's it's it's a
different genre yeah it's a by dudes and
says sort of it's sort of a sort of a
resource management
battlefield simulation alright it's like
you have to there is
a strategy of you know but but you're
not placing towers you're just sort of
like your guys car you know anyway the
point I was trying to make without
getting too long-winded is I played this
game I don't see any reason that it has
to be connected to a network and a lot
of people don't have reliable network
service we don't because we're in the
middle of the Android building where
people feel completely free to just use
all of the available airspace for random
test projects absolutely well you know
our Wi-Fi and you do have to realize
when you have when you have several
thousand devices on the Wi-Fi in a
building it's going to stress things out
now I think actually this device has
just lost Wi-Fi I think I you know that
due to you know probably some sort of
issue I don't know it's an airplane mode
ha
nevermind oh well there you go but that
brings my brings from I my other point
which is hey know where you know where
I'd love to play games on your hands
yeah you know and it's true that you
know not everybody travels as much as
you learn we're good yeah okay but we're
not what I'm gonna look at cartoon wars
because it's not a tower defense game we
wanted to mention that I wanted to
mention that I actually like playing
games offline so I do I do do and test
that and let's get into the actual tower
defense games themselves now we're gonna
go pretty quickly through things we've
looked at already so why don't we why
don't we start with one of the classics
fieldrunners
absolutely just to kind of display it
now I'm not sure we have a title card
for this one right oh we might not so so
we're just we're just gonna have to go
to a non title card equipped display and
there we are and and fieldrunners is one
of them there's there's a couple of
variations in the genre and fieldrunners
is the variation where you get to work
where you have guys running from one
side to the other and you actually get
to change their course by by putting
down towers right it's an open field
with path defined by towers exactly and
and and and and and the key strategy
element is the characters will always
take the shortest path to from one side
to the other so your goal is to make
their path long and then just when you
think you've gotten you've gotten you
know it's all taken care of
tarah carob they'll have you realize
that people actually will fly in the
shortest path over and we'll ignore all
of your defenses so ultimately you have
to make some decisions whether you're
going to continue to build towers in the
moat in the most logical crazy pattern
or whether you're going to build towers
that will hit planes let's contrast that
with oh by the way let's scratch that
with another tower defense game that's
that's been quite popular it's also a
very good game but it can takes a
completely different approach where
everything is constrained the both the
location of the towers and the paths
that people are going to follow you know
this game is is a beautiful game
absolutely and actually you know it's
interesting because this this game
involves levels that have a significant
amount of craft in the levels because
the goal of the level is to provide a
puzzle for which towers you place where
and they limit the number of options and
so in a sense in a sense this game this
game has a little more of different kind
of a variation like the design of the
levels is actually more critical than
the design of the individual elements a
lot of times they'll throw they'll throw
new players at you in order to in order
to change the game up a lot and this one
act or through new enemies this game
actually does both it throws completely
different levels and completely
different enemies and you have to use
different strategies based upon the
places you're actually allowed to place
towers but it's not as open-ended and
yeah it's a yeah I agree it's more of a
puzzle type of atmosphere it doesn't
feel like I'm playing a strategy game it
feels like I'm trying to figure out what
the correct combination is and that can
that can be its own set of fun Adelie
fences is has a fairly typical user
interface where you're dragging towers
from some ux/ui area and this gets down
in the corner and then you're placing
them on specific points on the map yeah
one of the things I actually one of the
UI changes to feel like you have to
collect them yeah one thing you see I
just completely screwed this up
because that the blue tower doesn't
doesn't do anything against the red guys
yes that's right but you can have a
tower that does both red and blue yes
exactly that's actually and that's
actually one of the unique things about
this game is that they actually have
this this concept of towers that are
that are that are ineffective against
one color or another and that's not
going to probably build faster but yeah
and now that that's another interesting
thing is that some some games will have
towers that build medially and someday
and some games will have towers that
take a little bit of time
another thing that will differentiate
these is when we pause can we still
build towers exactly and and some games
are sort of real-time tower defense
games this one is is it true is a true
real-time tower defense game that's the
only way it's played now from a menuing
structure there's really two styles one
is where you dragged in the corner and
another one is where you select where
you want to build and by the way this is
one of these things where if you have
icons sometimes it's tricky to see just
what caught what your icon is actually
going to do at any given point so yeah
so this this this kind of this K this is
the is the drag one I actually really
like the collect select where you want
to build a tower and get a menu on the
spot because it's less it's less
clicking definitely let's take a look at
one that does that so come to us a large
Korean game company has actually
copyrighted the trademarked the term
tower device so hi any any game that
calls itself tower defense or has tower
defense in the title will actually get a
nice polite letter from their lawyers
but yeah tower defense has a nice UI to
it where most of the UI elements are
hidden until you absolutely need them
you know is it yes clicking on the
screen will actually activate them and I
did really like that in this game this
game is really nice high-res sharp
graphics it's it's it's fun my that's
the only thing about this particular
game is this is this is another one this
is what I wish this is a fixed path
tower defense game so it's not as
limited in jelly defense in the sense
that you can you can place towers in
lots and lots of different varied places
but the path in which the in which the
characters run is is fixed
right and buddy's really cool just be
able to build towers kind of totally
nilly like that and you can see there's
actually you know this this and they
build immediately on this one yeah
exactly there's there's not nearly as
much time you know okay so I think we've
compared and contrasted some of the
styles let's talk about some of the you
know jelly defense I think one of the
things that we saw is it actually just
want just one comment yeah so this game
has it has very very high resolution
background artwork but you can actually
see that on the icons and text it is a
little lower resolution than the screen
and you might not be able to see that on
the live stream but this is you know
even in this game which looks amazing if
they if we had a slightly higher
resolution font it would look a little
less blurry and so I would say that
would be my one comment on the visuals
here because otherwise the game is so
high resolution so past all of my files
are really high res Impala SH the the
backgrounds and without actually making
a higher resolution font that's that
that is going to make the game look
worse we see some other games here that
are fall into that trap as well but if
you're going to spend strangely enough
if you're going to spend some extra you
know real estate application real estate
on anything in terms of high resolution
a font is great especially you know
since you can for a lot of these games
take advantage of the fact that we have
really nice open type implementations if
you can get an outline font that will
work we do a pretty good job of
rendering that pretty quickly and that
that is really the way to go you'll see
a bunch of games that do use that as
well now you see this game also has
reasonably good animation it's not the
best I've ever seen there's no death
animation for the enemies it has the so
it's got the the feature where you can
actually call a wave early rate oh if
you wouldn't mind going to the tablet
now see not so easy is that when you're
on the other side yeah okay so you have
an early call button and this is
something that you'll see in a lot of
these games where you just you hit a
button and you can actually send out the
waves a little faster another thing
you'll see is being able to speed up
speed up time yeah because really these
are
of games where you take relatively few
actions but you do them very frequently
yeah and actually one things I really
like is you can actually see you in this
game and actually shows you as ways
they're coming through so I mean this
game is this game is good my main my
main thing about this game is that it is
you know it implements the basics of
tired events incredibly incredibly well
right but you know it's it's to me it's
not as fun as for the other games yeah I
thought I thought you know it's
definitely got a good selection of
powers and you have some some different
situations where you you need to use a
particular mix of towers and I like that
but I felt like I don't know I felt like
it introduced them a little too slowly
mm-hmm and I don't know there's just
something about the gameplay that that
wasn't quite as fun some of the maps
were yeah maybe a little too hard to
begin with this like anyway the back key
isn't really is not working here
not exactly the back key isn't working
so that's that's a real problem yeah
other than that oh yes do these things
yes we're kind of funny sometimes they
do come up the full screen but when
you're doing your when you're putting
especially your own ads on a tablet you
know you know that no that's another
thing there's some of the menus I kind
of wanted to see a little bit larger
when I was on the tablet in terms of
scale yeah yeah you could definitely use
a little bit more testing on on large
devices yeah but I mean overall the game
good it really does it's a beautiful
game and I just wanted to contrast jelly
defense really quickly
there's nothing now there's nothing
wrong with what they've done here but
the it's a little more obvious that
they've they've ported from a 4x3 build
and gone sixteen by nine I now we would
always prefer that you actually just do
a sixteen by nine build I mean that
that's always gonna look better but in
this case at least they haven't just
squished everything in letterbox the
whole thing or pillar-box the whole
thing they've got a a nice set of UI
around here oh it's got little trails of
all my finger that's sis yeah I mean
this game is really a working hard it
was nice it I really do do wish though
that you know it just honestly they all
they need is a little bit of extra
graphic on the side that's not
interacted and it yeah
I'm interacting with and it would be
just so beautiful and so that really is
all you need just yeah just fill those
out and you know and again you know
that's something that if you design at
the beginning it's really easy if you
come into it we're like oh all of a
sudden we need lots and lots of new art
that's that's that's hard so but I
really would love to see that for this
game that would be the thing that takes
it over the top and far as I'm concerned
as I said you know from a you know it's
it's a little bit of a preference what
style of tower defense game you prefer I
think for for people who haven't done a
lot of these games this is actually
really nice has a great entry level
really absolutely and look look at the
animation look at the care they've done
with you know all of the transitions are
perfect all of the you know just all of
the gameplay just it has these really
nice look and feel to it where
everything's moving and everything's
believable everything looks 3d and any
and the graphical style is brilliant and
I think actually everything I think a
lot of the elements may actually be 3d
I'm you know the they certainly do have
a giant 3d if you go back to if we go
back to the menu here no I don't want to
restart level I want to go this is
actually by the way one of my complaints
is this is how you get to the menu so
level selectors that other thing which
which doesn't look like anything right
well it looks like one of those it looks
like one of those dudes which is it
doesn't look like it means this but
actually this is the level selector here
which is which is a you know it kinda
looks like that guy it kind of looks
like that guy yeah and this is so this
is a nice 3d element and is cool and you
see we're in this incredibly cool space
display so you know again there's and
actually if we were if we didn't have
HDMI connected you would see that it's
actually even running a little more
smoothly than it and then it looks here
so Rhett the HDMI removes ten pounds I
mean yeah yeah it does it does hurt the
framerate a little but but yeah so this
is I mean beautifully beautifully done
game absolutely it's got feet alright
let's let's go back let's go look at
another one we want to cover something a
little different
well why don't we why don't we take a
look at Sentinel 3 settle 3 restore the
space station which one well let's start
with central 3 I want to kind of
contrast the space station so central 3
when I was on parental leave last year I
spent almost every waking moment that I
could playing central 3 I love this
there's a couple things that I really
loved about it
the first is it's a so it is a fixed
path tower defense game but there are
there are multiple paths that enemies
will come down but it's it's more more
interesting feature is that it has a an
avatar system where in addition to
building towers you also control this
guy in it in a suit of mecha armor that
has special powers special abilities
yeah it's awesome and and and on it adds
a really great twist the art style is
beautiful I mean this is this is a lot
of like a Starcraft or something like
that family well done this this this is
a gorgeous gorgeous game especially
download the HD pected yes so that's the
other thing what's also nice about this
game is that it actually comes with an
SD pack that runs pretty much everywhere
and then with just a little bit of
actually play some towers here so we
don't die now this again is the is the
drag-and-drop method of tower and I'm
not a big fan there's a few things about
this interface that that make it a
little bit difficult I think that first
the fact that you have to drag and drop
is annoying but but fine the fact though
that the UI actually sits over areas of
the map that not in this map but in
other maps are actually playable too so
you see like the pause and the
fast-forward button here those will
actually cover areas of the map where
you have to place towers and to me
that's unacceptable because it means
that I have to do a lot of map
navigation that's just in I for the sole
purpose of keeping the UI from getting
in my way so going with the philosophy
that you should always be fighting the
enemies in the game and not fighting the
UI I think this one fails just a little
bit now we actually talk to the
developers about that and there they
were looking into some some ways to fix
it they certainly helped some I think
the there used to be a big OpenFeint
button here
which nothing against open faith the
problem though was that if you press
that button it would start an open faint
cycle that took about 20 seconds and you
can get out of it
yeah yeah and it's very very easy to
press those by accident because you can
see if I wanted to you know place it how
are up here you know
well what's you know what am I trying to
do there am I trying to click the tower
place a tower or click the settings
what's it going to decide it decided I
was talking about actually did you place
a tower - uh yes it did yeah there's a
tower there see now I'll show you
because you have to zoom in there it is
yeah and see if I want to upgrade the
tower now they upgrade by you click on
the tower mm-hmm and hit the upgrade
button you can see that that tower is
almost impossible to update upgrade
without doing a zoom and zoom and it's
just it's one of those things where yeah
I know if they just limited the playable
areas a little bit you know it does help
me there's only two buttons but actually
to be honest you know the there's
there's no me I would actually say that
you could actually you know the
fast-forward button is nice to have I
mean that's that's have there well what
do you need both is it easy oh well no
no no so the fast-forward button is
fight the the pause button is actually
really important because in this game
absolutely yeah you want it you want to
be able to pause and but you know it put
it in an area where you're not gonna
have a lot of gameplay one of the major
problems for this game is that there are
maps where the first choke point is
underneath one of these buttons you know
so all of the initial action is confined
to just a corner of the screen and if
you're if you're just in a corner of the
screen and there's buttons in the way
you can be immensely frustrating mm-hmm
absolutely
but this so there's a couple of other
things that are interested in so you got
the Avatar you've also got these gates
that he defends you get bonus points if
the gates don't fall but the level
doesn't end if the gate Falls so you
actually have several different things
that you're defending and not just your
ultimate
you also have the ability to collect
resources in later levels although I
felt that was balanced a little poorly
because I could never get to the point
where resource collection was actually
paying for itself also one thing that's
interesting is that it is by placing
towers in this case close to my mine
named Sentinel that actually gives them
it actually makes them more powerful
that's what that little circle there
means right and as you Sentinel gains
levels that circle actually gets bigger
so you have this thing and of course
that affects your strategy later on when
there's multiple gates that enemies
could be coming through because what
you'll do is you'll lie you'll send your
Sentinel over to one gate and then
another one starts getting attacked so
you jump over there and you really need
to pay attention to where that guy is
yeah it adds a lot of RPG there's
there's you know RPG elements and these
kind of games are cool and I think you
know I think that's this game so this
can matches it up a little even though
it is even even though it's basis it is
what we call fixed path which is one of
the simpler kinds of these games I'm
actually kind of sad because one of the
games that I that I played a lot was
guns and glory and that's that's all
they're not a very similar kind of thing
about theme that's a fixed path game as
well and and so I was kind of sad that
it didn't get nominated but nominated
well I should have but I was sort of odd
there were so many nominations already
that were good I decided we'd just stick
with the ones yeah that's a good point
and and by the way thank you very much
we were really excited to see so many
nominations in this category it's really
exciting when we can find games that we
haven't seen before and we feel like
really under thing some diamonds in the
rough by getting you guys involved so we
really appreciate that with that in mind
why don't we take a look at one of the
games that we haven't looked at before
alright so there's a couple of
interesting ones here and I you know
what we this is what we haven't looked
at on the show versus what we've looked
at elsewhere which we want you pick one
of these since I know that I look at all
well they have the Knights yeah so I
hadn't seen the Knights tone at all this
is a Unity game and you can tell right
you can tell because it's actually using
an older version of unity I'll wait this
game 1 of this divert this
this game might actually crash I can't
remember whether I got this game to work
now that I'm thinking about it well okay
so yeah so we'll totally take a look at
that later that was the one game that I
hadn't had a chance to look at now that
I know that no that's because well I'm
sure can pick them
how about myth defense but yeah that the
fact that had that unity splashing means
they're using a really really old
version of unity so all right so they
need up they do need to update that so
this was pretty neat defense is
beautiful actually I was really I was
really really glad to see that but do we
have a title card for this one or not
yeah this is one of the ones it's no
actually I didn't think we had title
parts for the first ten so we should
probably spend very little time on this
yeah exactly
but but this game actually I really
really like and so I'm glad we kind of
got to mention it it is definitely in
the non fixed path style of tower
defense games but I really like the the
fact that it's using this particular
theme and you see I was able to just you
know continue back from where I where I
left off you know in well almost I mean
you had a game in progress but it still
made you go through all those menus to
begin with that's kind of annoying it's
true it's true but actually but if I
click I think I actually didn't fully
close the game so okay so if I just did
home mm-hmm what's what's gonna happen
and then and let's let's try out to find
out this is a really good question
restoring so I'm right there and I just
get have to hit play in order to
continue so that's that's good
it did the right thing there I was I
think the fact that depended completely
close now whether or not the only thing
I don't remember is whether I hit the
home screen or I think I did exit the
game before so Elena legitimately
because I was testing what what happened
when the back key was pressed so I like
I like the artwork is really pretty the
the style is fun you know it is it is
again this is this is this is the most
you know traditional lights they have
these kinds of games I think you know
we're always really impressed when
someone takes a time to really do a good
job at these high-resolution displays
and remember this is an Asus Transformer
Prime this is you know by far not the
highest resolution display that's gonna
be on the market this year I think
you've already talked about at least one
1080p display but but you can tell that
the crispness of these graphics
especially if we zoom in a little bit
on these graphics right oh you'll see
that each one of the graphics from the
towers to the UI is really really
detailed it's not just high-res it's
detailed high-res you know look at those
cobblestones look at the the detail on
those towers look at the vegetation it's
amazing it's really really well done and
that's impressive to me yeah absolutely
and the other thing I would say about
this one is it you know if you look at
this game you look at the tower you know
come to us ask our defense game
side-by-side if you look at the tiles in
the background they look relatively
similarly detailed but if you look at
the fonts here the fonts here are really
showing really high res and that makes
use different they're also rendered in a
style that that looks semi 3d and it
just adds still a bit of a drop shadow a
little bit of a Jo and it also get a
little bit of of a gradient on them and
it just it looks really pro I mean I
they did a really nice job with this so
again you know I haven't played the game
long enough to be able to give a big
give a full you know in-depth review but
why I like what I've seen so far you can
see by the way that this is not a full
16 by 9 playing surface it's not four by
three either so it's interesting I'm not
sure where where that came from but or
maybe it was four by three and they're
just chosen to do it this way right can
you zoom no okay so that's interesting
yeah so what you can see is they've done
a little bit of fill on the edges and by
doing a tiny bit of fill on the edges
they've made something that I think
actually works on both a four by three
and a sixteen by nine just as easily and
it looks great it looks intentional on
both resolutions instead of looking like
it's been ported from one or the other
exactly what they did I you know putting
this little little border on the side
here in order to in order to get some
additional additional real estate you
know makes a huge different having black
bars so you know sometimes it's even a
little thing like that makes a huge
difference and again notice that the
borders are not just borders they've
also moved the UI into those areas so
it's not wasted space absolutely this is
great because the more UI on the playing
field the more
the game will get honestly yeah yeah and
this is it's great to have people to get
that stuff out of out of the way and
they really do a good job with that so
yeah in general you know this this is
this is a model if you don't actually
want to go deeper and create like would
have been you would be nicer if they
extended this border all the way out and
it didn't look like there was this hard
ledge here on the sides but if you but
if you can't do that this is the next
best thing and it honestly it really
makes a huge difference it doesn't it
may not seem like it but if we just saw
black bars here it would feel wrong it
would feel like we're watching
experience it was just less it would
yeah and if you've got a solid color
that's even worse so and this is
something that developers should
understand that this year Google is as
you can see with the launch of the Nexus
7 very very serious about Android
tablets and so we've talked to the play
team and they've said to us many times
that they are going to stop as much as
possible
stop featuring games that don't have
good tablet support you know there are
some some apps and some games just don't
you know they're not a natural talent
fit but I mean honestly almost any game
is gonna play better on something like a
nexus 7 that it's gonna play on most
phones and remember too that tablet
owners tend to buy about four times as
many games as phone owners yeah burning
up her owners memory yes it's you know
people look at them as consumption
devices people buy a lot of de phones
they use them as a phone they use it for
their Gmail but a lot of people buy
tablets really do you think of it as a
primary gaming device as well as you
know as well as another consumption
device so so yeah if you're doing
another bubble breaker that's just gonna
you know help somebody to waste time
where they were waiting for the bus you
know maybe you can get by with phone
version but if you're doing a great
detailed game like this you should
absolutely be planning for Android
tablets of all shapes and sizes
so let's take a speaking of tablets
let's let's go to a completely different
kind of game this is alright genocide oh
nice oh and it's and you can actually
play this a head to head over over over
a land and it is portrait and so let's
let's play against the CPU will play
against the Green CPU here and you'll
see that it actually is a game that's
set up for two people to play against
each other
kind of by default so I've got some
things here I can actually start placing
placing my towers and this is again a
very different style of game you know I
was even sort of debating whether we
would call this a true tower defense
game there's also a couple of options
here I can actually start upgrading my
Miya Miya my characters that are that
are gonna be produced here and let's so
are you producing mobile characters or
you just are you just putting down
towers I'm sitting down character
they're gonna which are going to produce
which are gonna produce tanks or footmen
this is sort of I would say it's a so
each one of these guys are gonna produce
little characters that are ultimately
gonna do my battling for me
so the towers aren't actually aren't
aren't necessarily fighting themselves
although sometimes they are but they're
also producing characters interesting so
sort of a cross between a tower defense
is something more like cartoon words
then yes yes and so the graphics really
ugly I and I say that if I silly do you
think it's a no my eyes is it feels like
I'm playing a Commodore 64 is that
intentional I you know I think that
there's a lot of low res graphics
intentionally on this but I also you
know do feel that it's this weird
combination of both yeah I do that I do
see that that sword that looks kind of
high res do you think maybe maybe they
just stretched on this display um I
don't think so I think the thing I think
that the idea is a little the little the
little orcs artists irr are kind of a
thick throwbacks okay and and and that
the other graphics are intended to be
high-res unfortunately because the
resolution of this tablet is very high a
lot of them just look really really low
red I see but I really like I really
like the idea of head-to-head combat and
it makes so much sense with this kind of
with this tablet form factors so I you
know I just I can't wait to see you know
kind of where were you where they would
go with this like it seems like there's
a lot of potential here yeah you know
I'm not sure about all of the strategy
but you can build you know towers in all
sorts of different places and you see
they get attack from all sides now you
can draw AI just got killed by the CPU
I'm the lowest level so I clearly didn't
do a very good job that's cool you are
playing sideways I am playing sideways
and that's mostly to keep the cable from
from getting pulled out so you guys the
truth going on yeah we'd like some cable
glue or something exactly it's some some
duct tape would work I think so
so yes that's pretty much all I want to
say there you know as far as the game
itself yeah we obviously they're they're
resolution issues or in orc genocide I'm
not I didn't get a try though the WLAN
version but split-screen is kind of
awesome and that's why and this is what
really shines on a tablet and that's is
this is why I want to see them upgrade
their graphic like you know we could
play together here yeah exactly i summon
towers you can summon towers and and you
know again we can start sending guys out
oh do i have to explicitly send guys out
or they just can't happen they just
happen if you summon the right kind of
buildings apparently i am totally not
summoning the right kind of anything
because I'm just getting my ass kicked
here whatever dude well you know if it
isn't yeah what are you wrong here
you sound them dud defense buildings but
you didn't some of them ride somewhere I
someone you have to some of them
actually in front of where I where I
summon my TAC building attack bill sure
sure yeah yeah make sense so okay yeah
well you know lesson learned next game
so let's go on to let's see so let's get
back into the top ten okay so what work
genocide was in there right yes I was in
the top was in the top test right did we
have the title card for that right oh we
absolutely did yeah
did we use it we did well I've got you
guys actually we have a couple of
questions on on the YouTube stream and
on the only event stream so I thought I
throw awesome alright Oh straightforward
okay let's see so on YouTube we'd like
to know is it easy to make apps and
games if a person doesn't know anything
about it can they still do it or do they
have to study coding or something okay
hang on first and turn your producer cam
on rate oh I think the world wants to
see you use the Hangout thing oh no it's
just right so surrounded by a halo of
light as always okay yeah it gets a
little bit annoying something so
sir that is hey I'm coming up delaying
this going yeah yeah there is another
dance face but my cats are attentive
ready to look at the camera now you can
pretend to be me and so I think that I
am there we are so let's give it so so
I've been in in video games for almost
20 years now
and I think it's a really good question
you know can you make a video game
without knowing coding well no no you
really can't
oh yeah you can okay there are some
tools that will allow you to try and put
together a game but eventually it boils
down to some form of coding whether it's
typing in a language like C sharp or C++
or Java or whether it's you know
connecting bricks together in in some
sort of a game maker environment you you
are going to be writing computer
instructions yes I mean there are
certain kinds of tools that allow you to
build really cookie-cutter games that
are that are very very similar but you
know for even for a tower defense game
you want to know things like pathing you
want to make sure that those guys are
always following the shortest path that
requires a little bit of code you might
want to have some AI and a lot of other
kinds of games so even if you have a
system that gives you a lot of stuff for
free like that you're still gonna want
to code that being said you know there
are really great tools out there that
have a lot of the work for you and
honestly I'm a firm believer that anyone
with the drive can learn how to code oh
and you know I'm not okay because I used
to teach coding I used to a computer
science and the truth is if if coding
frustrates you and you really don't get
it
you are my experiences you probably
won't get it because the people that I
saw you're really successful in my
classes it's sort of clicked with them
fairly early on well and there's also a
difference between I think in my
experiences coding and coding class work
versus coding in like one of one of the
people I went to school with who was
terrible at coding class work became one
of the most sexual successful engineers
I know cool engineers you know I know
building so yeah I would say that I
would say that you know that mostly to
me it's you know at least at least a lot
of a lot of the coding is
about right well and it was optimistic
make a distinction too if you want to
build a game all by yourself
then yeah you're you you might be you
might end up with one of these tools
that help you to make a cookie-cutter
game but there's nothing really super
special about it but there are so many
things that you can do with a game that
don't involve coding and I think that
you would find that there are far more
frustrated coders out there with decent
game engine ideas and interesting ideas
about game design who don't have someone
that can produce art or animation or
music or even polished level design so
if you've got talents for games yeah and
you can you can share you know if you
know how to use blender or Maya or if
you know how to use Photoshop if you
know how to write music all of these
skills are in yet an incredible demand
and there's lots of people out there
that would love to help you code and
they're you know there's there's great
modding tools out there and that's one
thing you might want to start playing
with is one of it one of the you know
existing titles that has really really
great tools allow you to modify the
levels absolutely look at like
Bethesda's games always trip with great
modding tools and I've got to the point
where I haven't even finished Skyrim I
just like playing with the mods mm-hmm
absolutely there's some incredible and
make the game really enriches and
enhances the games down we have a lot of
games to get so we have other a lot
another another question that's oh yeah
one more question you mentioned the the
play team reviews several times in your
shows and they curious to know these the
related figure out if your has already
been reviewed they would be nice to have
this info even if the app is ultimately
rejected and the reason was given that's
a good question um I mean we have that
data and if you if you ping us we can
tell you we generally when when we
suggest apps and they get rejected we
generally don't contact the developer
unless they got rejected for a reason
that's easy to fix
but you know if you're if you're curious
yeah you know drop me an email tell me
what game it is and I'll look it up for
you and we might consider making that
information public but you know as with
all internal
Aysen making it public involves
something through a lot of who's yeah I
think I think I think it's a really
interesting thing you know I think I
think the best thing is to really give
feedback and so I think that you know if
a game is rejected because well it's
just never going to be featured it's not
very useful if the game is rejected
because it has this or this wrong with
it then then the developer is contacted
and I think the real question is was it
looked at at all right now yeah a lot of
people are feeling I feel like it goes
into a cloud and they don't know so I'd
loved I'd love to at least have a way
that a developer could check that would
be cool
that would be great okay so let's look
at a couple so look why don't we take a
look at Space Station yeah oh yeah this
is this is this is this is a cool game
now it does have the button of shame and
it does have beacon the compatibility
mode stuff in it which is sad yeah
what is it very sad what is interesting
about it though is that it does actually
have both HD and low resolution graphics
and that graphics are really different I
think that's part of the reason why they
love it I actually in some ways liked
the low res layout but the HD graphics
are really really nice it's very pretty
I'm very impressed and yeah the layout
isn't quite as creative you know that
circle thing is sort of a little bit
feels a little more thrown together but
it's very very crisp let's go ahead and
get into the game the interesting thing
about this game is you know while we've
talked about open field games where the
enemies path is determined by the towers
that you build and we've also talked
about fixed path games where the enemies
always follow a single path no matter
what you build this is a little more
interesting you start with a space
station core and then you build out from
that core and yeah ultimately you know
the goal is to and you kind of do two
things you got it you've got it you see
I've got to I've got asteroids
surrounding me I've got to actually
build power nodes so that I can mine the
asteroids and I don't right so you have
a resource collection issue as well as
just a defense issue exactly and and so
and the most important thing is to get
mining but you if you obviously mind too
much and you don't actually build the
fences then your miners will just get
destroyed so you've got to start
building things like like turrets
and you've got and unfortunately now
that I build miners I don't actually
have money to build anything else so I'm
just gonna try to collect as much as
much resource as possible but I've got
incoming destroyers I'm gonna get killed
here and go do you oh yeah this I'm
where they comin from where they come I
don't know see over in the top yeah you
can zoom in so I I'm the I'm your
potency now you got some money I have my
I don't like I can't feel anything
useful oh my god this yeah the the I
guess I'm not sure if it's from the zoom
or something else but the video is no
longer coming in I get a blank screen Oh
hold on let's try it one more time 1 2 3
plug this in it is very easy to lose the
connection on these on this particular
my friend of thinks HTM oka there we are
back to it yeah all right so see that's
what so is now building a missile
launcher be super useful and I almost
have enough money to do that or a rail
cannon so I'm almost there almost okay
missile launcher so this is cool because
most tower defense games will just give
you money for enemies killed so if
you're not killing enemies you don't get
anything whereas this one you've got
this sort of continuous thing so even
between waves of enemies you're cranking
up the money I think that's kind of kind
of a cool idea
absolutely and yeah you'll see now I
have I have another laser turret and it
takes time to build things if I don't
build the power nodes then I cannot
actually build out a laser turret there
because I have only a limited number of
connections also so there is there is
there's a lot of there's a lot of detail
in this game and you do need to know
where people are coming from to know
they're coming from there do I have any
defenses out there no that's where all
my miners are so this is this is a
really serious problem for me now so I'm
going to want to build oh do I not have
a power nodes that miner that's not good
so I'm getting completely squashed here
by these guys now how how important is
the actual topology of your station like
well or I should say the the physical
locations of things rather than general
topology the general topology is more
important okay you need to you need to
make sure there's enough
it's connecting things and yeah I'm
about to get lose a laser turret here
which is sad but at least he'll he'll
he'll start firing on that guy yeah so
this is its interests it is kind of more
of a hybrid because the while we have a
lot of elements of tower defense games
it feels like a tower defense games the
enemies to behave very differently they
come in from different directions they
sit there and they actually attack your
towers which is uncommon there are some
other tower defense games I think one of
the other ones towers and trolls I think
they will attack your your towers yes
and I'm a little I have mixed feelings
on that because especially for towers
and trolls I that felt a little gimmicky
that that felt like just okay well every
now and then I I look in my towers
health is down and I need to go fix it
with some yeah some money and that's
annoying whereas this it's like well
they're attacking my tower so and
they're stopping to attack yes so the
fact that they're attacking my tower has
some significant impact on the way the
the defense is going to go absolutely
and the goal is usually here to survive
for a period of time usually you're
waiting for reinforcements or something
like that and and so you may not
necessarily defeat these enemies and
your main space station also has a
certain amount of health so it's it's
it's not it's holding off you know
various things for a long enough period
of time let's build one more of these
guys I'm it's it's sending an enormous
quantity of enemies at me right now so
but yeah I think you know it terms of
smoothness it's a pretty smooth game the
graphics are pretty good I think they
could be a little bit higher resolution
and even HD it always bums me out a
little bit when games allow you to zoom
in maybe one or two steps further than
they should yeah essentially you know as
soon as a pixel in your art covers more
than a pixel on the screen that's
probably where you ought to stop yeah I
see now I'm about to lose all of my
defenses here but I only have to survive
for another five seconds there you go
so I may may actually make it despite
everything you are yeah yeah I see
victory so even though like I got here
lately obliterated you know I still I
still actually made it to the level Oh
so I think I want to close down with
anomaly HD is that just that that is a
bit of a genre buster there so anomaly
puts you sort of on the other side is at
our offense game a lot of people have
tried this a lot of people have said I'm
gonna build the tower offense game
wouldn't be interesting if we turn tower
defense on its head this is one that I
think has succeeded better than most you
can see first that they've got an
extremely professional-looking intro
really reminds me like a desktop video
game or a console game mmm
the the UI is very crisp the gameplay is
very interesting I wouldn't say they've
nailed it I wouldn't say I feel like
this is really the reverse of a tower
defense game but it was beautiful
yeah it's a beautiful game and it's a
lot of fun essentially what you do is
you're you have a convoy of enemies
essentially that are going to attack
towers or try to get through towers Oh
advanced difficulty oh yeah feeling
frisky today are we yeah absolutely all
right then I'm wearing the Android hat
I've got the Android Jesus look going so
excellent act like or Android Santa the
Android Santa has something like that so
alright so and I actually haven't played
it on this tablet so this is the first
time it's run here so my my apologies
you're getting to see all of the all of
the starts of the game yeah notice how
crisp and smooth all of that is exactly
it's really well done and again I think
you know you know again even even here I
I can I can zoom in and out I can pan
around it's you know so so I'm now
playing again my goal is I can I can
change my route here however I want to
get to the target so I can go like that
if I want to obviously that's not going
to help me so that you know again again
I do so well and you can change it in
the middle of the game to you right but
that's that's what this game is about
it's about planning your route based on
where the towers are you do have some
offensive weaponry you also end up
getting
power-ups through the game and so
planning the route and determining when
to deploy your power-ups is the extent
of the gameplay and it ends up being a
lot of fun when I played it I know check
that out
wow that's a great transition and those
are some beautiful graphics when I
actually played the game it held my
attention for a while eventually I felt
like that the number of choices I had in
the gameplay maybe weren't enough to
keep my interest for a long time mm-hmm
there are some it they do have some
interesting twists yeah then this is the
strategic part is I can I can deploy a
repair icon as well and and then I and I
tap where I want it to be deployed so in
this case I wanted to play deploy it on
top of my on top my guys here so boom
now you can start him going now I can
start them going check ball hood and you
say I've got a certain amount of repair
so I've got to use that and
strategically also in the game make it
better get some smoke shadows yeah
there's also - great yeah on here you
know again this is a game that could
have been done as a 2-d game but doing
it in three just allows okay obviously I
just I would I just start from
checkpoint yes doing it in 3d just
allows for that much more awesomeness
and in this case you can you can see all
these details are enabled through 3d so
you could drop the repair like down
there or something yeah yeah excuse me
that's a sneeze bless you alright I
didn't hike gesundheit
alright let's repair a little bit there
come on guys yeah and that's really what
it is right it says how how you deploy
the repairs and the other power-ups is
and see in this case you really haven't
deployed it well you need to deploy it
so so the the trailing edge is there but
but every time you destroy a tower this
airplane comes by and dropped you
something cool it's a great effect
although I did kind of get mad after a
while it's like a airplane yeah why
don't you just drop the stuff I need
when I need it exactly
but you know then the video game world
logic doesn't always make sense anyway
we're just about out of time but we did
want to show you anomaly warzone earth
it's a great game really really
impressive graphics like I said the
gameplay maybe isn't for everybody and
certainly not a tower defense game but
it's an interesting riff on the genre
and so we like it thanks a lot everyone
for all your tower defense suggestions
now we tried to get through as many
suggestions that we could today and I
don't know I part of me feels like that
was awesome and part of me feels like
maybe we didn't get through or maybe we
didn't spend enough time on each game
what do I you know I I will personally
say it I've spent an enormous amount of
time playing these games no I meant no I
meant talking about my show right yeah
yeah no I mean I think that you know I
think that we really gave people a
feeling of the genre we got through some
of the best games you know hopefully
there's a few there that we didn't get
through we will definitely do another
segment like this there's no need or the
fans means so absolutely let us let us
know what you'd like to see let us know
what you think of today's show we're
very interested in oh now again the the
edited version will be up on YouTube
momentarily hopefully tonight and next
week we will be back with another theme
which is driving games and now get busy
and nominate because I don't think
there's laughter my look there is
nothing yeah nothing in the category
like tower defense driving games is a
pretty broad category we're not going to
kick anything out if as long as it
involves driving in some ways exactly
anyway you don't want just my
nominations because ultimately I will
just nominate the whole cast and they
will be all about zombies to be clear
does that include golf games no no no we
are talking about game the games where
you drive the vehicle driving driving
yeah but that is a good point though
that is a good point yeah yeah thank you
for clarifying because we would have had
some embarrassing situations on our hand
right now yeah well actually it could
have been quite entertaining really
indeed but so what do you think about
like something like demolition Earth is
that a driving game I mean there are
cars right yeah but you're not driving
them you're just like like you know so
you know get a game like you know I
think any kind of racing game is really
what we're talking about here until to a
large degree but if it has driving as a
major mechanic we'll consider it okay
so sounds good racing probably be a
little bit closer so we're talking about
things like lane splitter or the need
for CV and various that kind of thing so
claim all right so go ahead and nominate
your favorites especially nominate the
favorites that you haven't seen us
feature or I got from the big guys our
grand theft auto to be a driving game
that's true it is frequently a driving
yeah absolutely yeah so nominate your
favorite driving games we love take a
look at we'll probably take the top five
we might drop a couple of them out if
it's something that Google Play is
featured in the past or has given a lot
of promotion to because the intent of
this show is to find the stuff that
really hasn't been looked at as much but
either way you know nominate what you
want and also when you nominate
something please include your Google
Play ID or link to your Google Play
profile because whereas in the past
we've had the developers on now that
anyone can nominate we actually want to
know why you liked the game and if you'd
like to come on the hangout with us and
talk about why you like a particular
game if you include your Google+ link we
will absolutely invite you to the
Hangout and get you on air so is that
about it that's about it all right we'll
see you next week when we talk about
driving games thanks for joining us
you